Viktor Orbán se ha convertido en el Johnny
Depp de la política europea.
El primer ministro de Hungría lleva mucho
tiempo llamando la atención de Bruselas y
del resto de capitales europeas... y no precisamente
por su simpatía.
Al húngaro ya solo le ríen las gracias en
Polonia.
Durante años a Orbán se le ha permitido
de todo en la Unión Europea: desde dejar
que se haga con todo el poder en Hungría
hasta ver cómo el propio gobierno húngaro
pagaba campañas contra Juncker cuando este
era el presidente de la Comisión Europea.
Campañas pagadas, por supuesto, con dinero
público.
Y claro, todo esto son cosas que escuecen
en Bruselas.
Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que Hungría
es uno de los principales receptores de fondos
de la Unión Europea.
El problema para Orbán es que ahora tantos
años de excesos comienzan a pasarle factura.
Su última decisión sobre prohibir a menores
todo aquel contenido que se considere que
"promueve la homosexualidad” está siendo
algo así la gota que colma el vaso.
Bruselas parece ahora decidida a tomarse la
cuestión de Orban muy pero que muy en serio.
[Y me diréis, ¿pero en qué están pensando?
¿van a prohibir will y grace?
Pues para que os hagáis una idea ni Harry
Potter parece que se salvaría de la censura.]
Todo esto ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos
hagamos unas cuantas preguntas.
¿Qué demonios busca el gobierno húngaro?
¿Están fundamentadas las críticas contra
Orbán?
¿Qué papel puede jugar la Unión Europea?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Qué puede pasar en el futuro?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas.
Pero antes, antes vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
(ORBÁN, EL BASTIÓN CONTRA EL COMUNISMO)
Hubo un tiempo en el que Viktor Orbán fue
todo un símbolo de la lucha por la libertad.
Corrían los años 80 del pasado siglo y Hungría
aún era un régimen comunista bajo la influencia
de la Unión Soviética.
Sin embargo, amigos, aquel entonces el bloque
del Este ya se estaba empezando a desmoronar.
Y justo en ese escenario, es donde encontramos
al joven Viktor Orbán, uno de los fundadores
del partido Fidesz, los Jóvenes Demócratas.
Orbán era considerado como uno de los disidentes
más carismáticos, y luciendo pelazo, participó
con 26 años en el homenaje de Estado a los
restos de los líderes de la Revolución húngara
de 1956 con un firme discurso contra el comunismo
y en favor
de la democracia.
Efectivamente, el régimen socialista soviético
cayó.
Y Fidesz se convirtió en un partido político.
Pero en las primeras elecciones no les fue
nada bien.
Así que… giro de timón.
Orbán abandonó su posicionamiento liberal
para convertir al Fidesz en el gran partido
de la derecha conservadora de Hungría.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Funcionó.
(En 1998 Orbán se convirtió en el primer
ministro de Hungría.
Fue un primer mandato de 4 años con buenos
datos económicos, y que avanzó en la modernización
poscomunista de Hungría.
Incluso, su buen hacer llamó la atención
del Partido Popular Europeo, la agrupación
de partidos de centro-derecha en el Parlamento
Europeo.
Así que fueron a Budapest para convencer
a Orbán de que su sitio estaba con ellos
y no con los liberales.
)
Y así es como el Fidesz se integró en el
Partido Popular Europeo.
La vida sonreía a Orbán salvo por un pequeño
inconveniente: perdió las elecciones para
revalidar su Gobierno.
Y en 2006 las volvió a perder.
Tocaba un nuevo giro de timón en la forma
de hacer política.
Desde ese momento mucho más radical, combativa
y porqué no decirlo populista.
Y cuando recuperó el poder en 2010, lo hizo
a lo grande.
Lo hizo con una supermayoría de 2 tercios
del Parlamento con poder suficiente para cambiar
a su antojo la Constitución.
Y como bien sabéis vosotros, jóvenes demócratas
del mundo que nos estáis viendo, ese es el
peor superpoder que se le puede dar a un político.
Porque desde entonces desde Hungría sólo
nos llegan noticias como esta:
(Los jueces de Hungría advierten sobre las
amenazas a la independencia judicial)
Dirigiendo el Gobierno desde su cargo de primer
ministro y el Parlamento con esa supermayoría
de 2 tercios, Orban siempre ha tenido a la
Justicia en su punto de mira.
Para empezar creó una Oficina Nacional de
la Judicatura con capacidad para vetar los
ascensos judiciales e influir en el reparto
de casos.
¿Que los jueces plantan cara al Gobierno?…
pues les adelanto de golpe 8 años la edad
de jubilación.
Que el Tribunal Constitucional sigue dando
guerra... pues amplió el número de magistrados
y reservo las vacantes para los más afines
a Fidesz.
El caso es que de una forma u otra Viktor
Orbán parece tener siempre la última palabra.
(La separación de poderes en Hungría ha
ido perdiendo fuerza progresivamente.
Cada vez que ha recibido un revés, Fidesz
ha utilizado su supermayoría para blindar
la agenda de Orbán enmendando la Constitución.
Pero es que, además, el dominio de Orbán
sobre la democracia húngara no acaba aquí.
Las elecciones, por ejemplo, son libres, sí,
pero no equilibradas.
La Oficina de Auditoría del Estado, dirigida
por un exdiputado de Fidesz, ha investigado
a los partidos de la oposición e incluso
les ha impuesto multas millonarias, ahogándolos
financieramente.
Algo que, por supuesto, no ha hecho con el
partido en el gobierno, ¿Casualidad?
Ja.)
¿Es entonces Hungría una dictadura?
Pues, no, evidentemente no.
Pero hay detalles que hablan por sí solos.
Por ejemplo, desde que gobierna Viktor Orbán,
se les ha dado derechos de voto a unos 2 millones
de húngaros que viven en países vecinos
del este de Europa.
Se les permite votar por correo; en su mayoría
son apoyos garantizados al Fidesz.
Sin embargo, los aproximadamente 350.000 ciudadanos
húngaros que viven en Europa Occidental tienen
que ir a embajadas y consulados para votar.
Facilidades para unos.
Dificultades para otros.
No hay pucherazo ni se liquida a los líderes
de la oposición.
Pero es que a Orban ni siquiera le hace falta.
Muchos periódicos críticos han cerrado y
Fidesz ha transformado MTI, la agencia pública
de noticias del país, en un órgano de propaganda
cuyo servicio para colmo es gratuito, lo que
ha acabado con las agencias de noticias competidoras.
Simple y llanamente con la estrategia más
antigua de la política: competencia desleal
pagada con dinero público.
Y claro, como podéis imaginar, los periódicos
más pequeños, los regionales… Todos se
surten en gran medida de noticias de esta
agencia gubernamental, por supuesto siempre
favorables al Gobierno.
Y con las radios y las televisiones pasa prácticamente
lo mismo.
Ya lo véis,.
Orbán lo tiene todo bajo control.
Pero esperad un momento amigos, porque las
cosas han cambiado desde que en marzo pasara
esto:
(El Fidesz de Orbán deja el grupo parlamentario
del Partido Popular Europeo antes de ser expulsado)
Orbán se beneficiaba hasta el pasado marzo
de formar parte del grupo político que domina
el Parlamento Europeo y que tiene la mayor
capacidad para marcar el camino a la Comisión
Europea.
Era un aliado incómodo para la centroderecha
europea pero… al fin y al cabo, el húngaro
Fidesz era el tercer partido que más europarlamentarios
aportaba al Partido Popular Europeo.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, amigas, ahora
sus socios de Bruselas se han hartado de soportar
los desafíos de Orbán.
Un momento, ¿que de qué tipo de desafíos
estamos hablando?
Pues… Atentos.
(ORBÁN, EL HÚNGARO NACIONALISTA)
Hay dos motivos por los que los húngaros
votan a Orbán.
Uno tiene mucho que ver con las emociones.
Para muchos húngaros ser partidario de Viktor
Orbán y el Fidesz, dos bastiones de la independencia
nacional, es algo así como ser un buen patriota.
Pero claro, no nos engañemos, el tiempo pasa,
y con la Unión Soviética más disuelta que
los Beatles desde que Yoko Ono pisó Gran
Bretaña comprenderéis que eso de motivar
a los húngaros con el enemigo comunista es
algo que iba perdiendo tirón.
Y justo aquí es dónde sale a relucir el
olfato político de Orban.
¿Qué hay que hacer para seguir en el poder?
Está claro, ¿no?
Fabricar un nuevo enemigo.
Y tal y como decimos por aquí,, dicho y hecho.
¿Recordáis la crisis de los refugiados de
hace unos años?
Pues esta fue la principal aportación de
Viktor Orbán.
(Si lleva a su país masas de inmigrantes
indocumentados del Medio Oriente, está importando
terrorismo, crimen, antisemitismo y homofobia.
Viktor Orbán.)
No sé, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Más allá de los prejuicios que contienen
declaraciones como esta, no parece que sea
la mejor forma de que un líder político
aborde una crisis de refugiados derivada de
una cruenta guerra civil.
Incluso aunque no esté de acuerdo con dar
cobijo a esas personas.
[Un poco de humanidad]
El caso es que Orbán construyó una barrera
de alambre de púas en la frontera para evitar
que los refugiados entraran en Hungría.
Todo en defensa de lo que el líder hungaro
considera una contrarrevolución dirigida
contra los que mandan en Bruselas para reivindicar
el carácter cristiano de Europa.
Y ya puestos ahí no iba a quedar todo.
Orbán ha atacado repetidamente al inversor
estadounidense George Soros como símbolo
de la globalización.
Soros es dueño de la Universidad Centroeuropea,
la más prestigiosa de Hungría y que el Fidesz
ha expulsado del país por promover los valores
que no coinciden con los del gobierno.
Y muchos estaréis pensando: ¿Igual es un
poquito excéntrico señalar como enemigo
público número 1 de Hungría a un tío que
vive en Nueva York?
Bueno, puede ser, pero mientras los húngaros
están preocupados enfrentándose con supuestos
enemigos como Soros o los pobres refugiados,
los informes de la OLAF, la Oficina Europea
de Lucha contra el Fraude sugieren que el
gobierno hungaro no está perdiendo el tiempo.
(Los datos de la OLAF sobre las irregularidades
en el uso de fondos de la Unión Europea golpean
a Hungría de nuevo)
Todo apunta a que el Fidesz ha hecho rico
a su círculo más cercano gracias al dinero
venido de Europa.
Y muchos diréis, pero bueno a la mayoría
de la gente no le suele gustar que los políticos
metan la mano en la caja.
¿Cómo es que le siguen votando?
Pues aquí encontramos el segundo motivo por
el que los húngaros votan a Orbán.
Y es que lo cierto es que, mientras ha estado
de primer ministro, la economía húngara
ha progresado.
El desempleo ronda el 4%, lo que es música
para los oídos de los húngaros, que devolvieron
al poder a Orbán en plena crisis de la Gran
Recesión.
Además, la Hungría de Orbán ha crecido
a un 3% de media hasta la llegada de la pandemia
del covid-19.
¿Tiene mérito?
Pues depende.
Si, por ejemplo, tenemos en cuenta que cada
año Hungría recibe en ayudas europeas el
equivalente a cerca del 3% de su PIB… pues
hombre, muy mal tendrían que gestionar uno
de los países que más dinero recibe de la
Unión Europea.
Mirad.
Para meterse tanto con los que mandan en Bruselas,
no está nada mal, ¿eh?
De todas formas hablaremos de la economía
húngara en un próximo vídeo, así que,
ya sabéis, no olvideis suscribiros para estar
al tanto.
El caso amigos, es que el Fidesz podría estar
a punto de perder el control de la situación
tras la llegada de la pandemia.
Ya os hemos contado que ya no forma parte
del Partido Popular Europeo, el grupo más
numeroso del Parlamento Europeo.
Pero es que además otros países se están
hartando de los ataques de Orbán a Bruselas
y de ver cómo el dinero de los contribuyentes
europeos se lo están llevando a manos llenas
los colegas del primer ministro húngaro.
Así que en las negociaciones de los fondos
para la recuperación post-pandemia, los europarlamentarios
introdujeron exigencias nunca vistas hasta
ahora.
(Acuerdo alcanzado para vincular la financiación
de la Unión Europea con el respeto del Estado
de derecho)
El Gobierno húngaro ha puesto todos los palos
en las ruedas posibles para evitar que este
reglamento salga adelante.
Pero todo indica que la estrella europea de
Orbán está a punto de apagarse.
Y lo que es peor para él: ahora tiene otras
preocupaciones que atender.
Atentos.
(ORBÁN, EL ESTRATEGA ELECTORAL)
Hungría ha protagonizado muchas noticias
durante la pasada Eurocopa.
Lo malo es que fue más por motivos políticos
que por éxitos deportivos.
El Gobierno de Viktor Orbán acaba de aprobar
la ley que prohíbe la exposición de los
menores de edad a cualquier contenido que
dé visibilidad a la homosexualidad.
La indignación fue enorme en buena parte
de Europa.
Y la Eurocopa fue el escenario en el que Orbán
encontró la expresión más popular del rechazo
comunitario a su legislación homófoba.
Recordad que Munich quiso iluminar su estadio
con los colores de la bandera arcoíris y
que el portero de Alemania lució un brazalete
con estos colores en el partido que les enfrentó
contra Hungría.
Un gesto similar protagonizó el piloto Sebastian
Vettel en el Gran Premio de Hungría de Fórmula
1.
Lo cierto es que muchos Gobiernos europeos
y la propia Comisión Europea le tienen ganas
a Orbán.
Hace unos años se intentó actuar contra
el Gobierno húngaro desde el Parlamento Europeo,
pero no pasó nada.
Sin embargo amigos, ahora la situación es
distinta.
(Cuando en 2018 el Parlamento Europeo decidió
poner en marcha las sanciones del Artículo
7 contra Hungría, se topó con un obstáculo
insalvable.
La decisión debía tomarse por consenso del
resto de países miembros de la Unión Europea.
Una misión imposible ante la alianza Budapest-Varsovia.
Ahora las cosas han cambiado con el nuevo
reglamento.
Ahora los países miembros deberán respetar
el Estado de Derecho y los valores fundamentales
del proyecto europeo como el respeto a las
minorías o la Comisión Europea podrá bloquearles
el desembolso de fondos comunitarios con el
beneplácito de una mayoría cualificada.)
Por supuesto, el Gobierno de Orbán va a presentar
batalla.
En un primer momento, bloqueó la aprobación
del presupuesto comunitario y las ayudas para
la recuperación postpandemia porque no querían
ver ni en pintura esa exigencia de respeto
al Estado de Derecho.
Pero amigos, al final tuvieron que ceder porque
son conscientes de que la llegada de los fondos
europeos, un auténtico pastizal, es algo
vital para la economía húngara.
Eso sí, Orbán consiguió arrancar una concesión:
el Tribunal de Justicia de la Unión Europea
tiene que dar el visto bueno a la legalidad
de esta nueva exigencia para recibir dinero
comunitario.
Todo esto parece que retrasará un par de
años el plazo para que la Comisión Europea
pueda plantar cara a los países miembros
con vocación de déspotas.
Y desde luego todavía es pronto para saber
si esto quedará en la típica regulación
que tanto gusta en Bruselas: reglas estrictas
para contentar a los más exigentes y una
aplicación muy flexible para tranquilizar
a los críticos.
La presidenta de Eslovaquia tiene las mismas
dudas.
(“Tener el mecanismo para defender el estado
de derecho tan solo es el primer paso.
Ahora tenemos que hacerlo funcionar”.
Zuzana Caputova, presidenta de Eslovaquia.)
En cualquier caso, si algo ha ganado Viktor
Orbán en su tira y afloja con el resto de
líderes de la Unión Europea es tiempo.
Tiempo para que la exigencia del respeto al
Estado de Derecho no se ponga en marcha antes
de la primavera, que es cuando se celebran
las próximas elecciones en Hungría.
(La oposición húngara se une para desbancar
a Viktor Orbán)
Estaremos atentos a los acontecimientos.
De momento turno para ti:
¿Crees que la Unión Europea se atreverá
por fin a plantar cara a Viktor Orbán?
¿O pensáis que cada país tiene que ser
soberano para decidir su camino sea este cual
sea?
Podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si aun no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.